number one i'm excited for your music
for your solo career why is
is a very great accomplishment for you
what is it what are you feeling right
now um
i'm feeling like like it's just
a breath of life it's like a sigh of
relief because
this whole album and the process of
making it i was just kind of nervous
because it's very different from what
i've been doing
um i feel like that with every album but
i think especially this one it's
like an album that's very personal and
uh it's it i guess
every album gets more and more personal
for me so i'm always just kind of like
kind of scared and nervous but also
excited at the same time so
i'm i'm really happy that everybody's
kind of vibing with it and uh following
me along on this journey
yeah you know a lot of people think
about we categorize an album coming out
that is obviously a um landmark
right but it is it is a post along your
journey it's not just
a destination in and of itself so when
you think about your journey
where are you on it right now
i think i was
i kind of view like my my time in uh in
my group
as like this one one hill and then
i was i went down it and i went on
another hill
and i did some self exploration and now
i'm going up another and going up a
steep hill right now so
i think i just i'm not i don't see the
top
but i'm i'm clap i'm climbing it right
now i'm climbing
what have you been learning about
yourself as a performer and an artist in
the process of putting this all together
um one of my my like mentors told me
like acceptance is
key accepting like my past
um respecting my past um and
i've always like talked about self-love
and
love yourself be yourself and i think
with this album i
when i was like really trying to write
out everything
uh it was like actually one of the first
times
that i actually wrote for myself and
in the ways that back then when i was
writing for labels i was
writing for other groups and other
clients um
and i was always even for my own music i
was like trying to
because i'm in this whole mindset of
like okay i can formulate
a pop track i can formulate a dance
track and i can formulate an rv
track but it's very analytical and it's
like
um and i think i got burnt out
and um and i'm trying to take this new
perspective of just like
just go with the flow actually be
actually be myself
like uh be more myself than ever
and be okay with that um and
i i just i i just i'm
in this process of experimenting and
exploring right now
yeah that's cool how does it change the
sort of the risk factor i guess is a way
to put it when you're writing
from such a personal place because now
you're
you know you're wearing your heart on
your sleeve you're exposing
yourself to your audience in a new way
how does that affect the way that you
anticipate how people will react to what
you're putting out there
uh i feel like back then um i because i
i do look at comments and i get feedback
from
uh you know the people listening to my
music and i always felt this sense of
insecurity well like
yeah i guess i could have done better or
like uh
i i just kind of had this insecurity of
like
but yeah i guess i could have done
better i could have done this but then
with why i kind of felt more i just felt
more empowered
because i was way more honest with
myself and i made
it the way that it was on purpose for
myself this is for me and this is my
truth
and i hope that um you know it's not
like uh
again back then we a lot of songwriters
and a lot of producers
we we all talk about like well the label
like this well
this artist like it now it's just like
are we vibing with this
yeah so it's kind of like just
approaching a different angle and
i've grown up in the industry since i
was 15 so as a 28 year old now i'm just
kind of like
now understanding like like to be really
creatively free and like
no this is the way that i want my song
this is the way that i'm feeling i can't
explain it
and i know that this is probably better
for views or
whatever it may be but now it's just
like but i just want it to be this
because this is how i felt this is my
truth and
this is my past and this is the way that
i want to want to tell it yeah it's
beautiful to see you doing your thing
there must be a different level of
satisfaction for sure
when you're able to put something out
and go ah like that was
i took that risk and and now it's out
there it feels good right
yeah i um was actually really funny
about uh one of the songs um vegas
on the album um it was actually a demo
that we got from um
the producers the wavies and uh it was
actually a different demo
and i remember that we were having a
listening session
and i remember no one no one really
vibed with it but i was like
wait there's something about this song i
had different lyrics it was
written diff a little bit differently um
and i
sat on it for maybe i think two three
months
and then suddenly let's go back to vegas
i was like that's the lyric that's the
lyric
um so i i took parts of the original
demo that was sent to me
and i just kind of made it different and
made it my own
um i kept parts of um the
the original uh track that the way he's
made for me and i just kind of
just re-told the story in my own way and
i think
that was a really fun process because i
it's it's
nice to see like kind of get back into
like how
songs and can evolve being passed to
different people
so i i thought um
number one thank you for casually
blessing us there with that
little let's go back to vegas beautiful
thank you
of course you know one of the things
that
i i think is really amazing about what
you're doing and really it's something
i'm jealous of it's about you can sing
in multiple languages
right the fact that because you're you
know the mindset is a bit different
because you're thinking globally right
you can reach all these people when
you're able to speak the language that
they speak to
do the songs i know the songs get
tweaked a little bit
right based on the language does it feel
different when you sing them in
the language sorry cut out for a little
bit i think i caught your question
though
um uh yeah the vibe is very different
and um
it's always i there's a thing in
songwriting that called phrasing um i
think other songwriters will use it too
it's just like the way that song
uh that sorry it's the way that certain
um
words are enunciated um so like
i can be like back or back like you know
like it's these little
small details and how the rhymes can
work and then
figuring out phrasings in in other
languages is also
a whole other like beast that i'm
tackling at the moment and i'm just
really blessed to have a good team with
me
to kind of guide me along that process
um
and like i with me singing now in
mandarin um i
i was um i'm just happy to send
something to my mom
because she's been such a a huge
supporter of my whole career
unconditional love always so
patient i don't call her for months and
then i suddenly like
mom what you doing tomorrow which is not
like waiting for you
and to be able to like just
show her music and let her uh see the
stuff that i've been doing and
english so now doing these in mandarin
like i feel like i'm a lot closer with
my mom
um and i i can talk with her more about
things and
my mom is an amazing singer by the way
um i
grew up with her singing to me uh
so it's nice to kind of try to be a good
daughter
working on a still not i'm not i'm not a
perfect daughter i'm working on it
slowly
i mean it's a journey it's a journey
it's a process
you